now the size they don't fight on their
own there's never a one so one it's they
call it Mamu which is like a pack of
socks you don't want you all jump on you
and I had that a few times
wanted me over there with a chair one
punch me in the head with these metal
rings
I'm biting this other one and I'm sorry
I'm not going I don't want to go down
because an over goes down
I'm not getting up
and then I've been this over there with
a bat
knock me out and I remember them waking
up
so this I thought it was a girl
Tavern
cotton ball over these cuts
I thought wow she's beautiful
who is she
I was a you know
and where they show me some compassion
and understanding and empathy
you know it was
it was nice to feel
that that kind of intimacy if you can
understand me